[Musica]
grazie a tutti e devo ammettere quando
mario mia mi ha chiamato per per parlare
per invitarmi qui abbiamo parlato come
riuscire a connettere l'appunto
l'industria chimica comunque quel
settore chimico io lavoro e l'empatia 1
una delle prime domande che mi è venuto
in mente è stato ma che cosa ci fa da
raccontare ma in realtà secondo me
quando il link tra empatia e kimi e
chimica industriale l'ho trovata una
cosa molto semplice cosa di tutti i
giorni che proprio un uovo e ora a
vedere un po come quando si parla di
empatia a livello tecnologico per me si
riferisce a questa domanda qua che cosa
perché c'è la necessità di una certa
tecnologia e soprattutto che cosa questa
tecnologia quali conseguenze ha a
livello planetario e il poter riuscire a
rispondere a questa domanda si collega
al concetto di awareness ovvero
consapevolezza ma è una consapevolezza
che deve essere molto solida basata su
fatti non una consapevolezza frivola
oggi un po tipica dell'area di su un po
dei social del fake news e ed è proprio
questa consapevolezza che grazie appunto
con tecnologia e innovazione può portare
a un cambiamento a un cambiamento
soprattutto nel livello della società
e adesso vedremo due esempi è il primo
dei quali appunto è proprio quello della
produzione di uova oggi
fondamentalmente sono tre grossi e tipi
di allevamento partito vero ma che sono
allevamenti in gabbia dall'altro lato
abbiamo gli allevamenti organici o
biologici è una via di mezzo invece sono
i cosiddetti allevamenti fu il range
dove diciamo le galline in questo caso
hanno la possibilità di fare sia al in
un ovaio chiusa al protetto ma anche la
possibilità di poter uscire ma andiamo a
vedere i numeri oggi in europa circa il
56 per cento del delle uova vengono
prodotte tramite allevamento in gabbia
mentre questi allevamenti organici e
fringe rappresentano una percentuale
praticamente molto bassa in realtà
voglio fare leva anche un altro esempio
della situazione della svizzera dove
appunto vivo nel già il popolo svizzero
in 1978
siccome consapevole di questo problema
del problema appunto che di queste
degli animali come soffrono in questa
gabbia sono hanno votato e sono riusciti
già nel 1992 a bandire completamente
questo tipo di allevamento ma in realtà
se guardiamo un attimino i numeri questi
elementi organici e free ranging in
svizzera non non fanno il cento per
cento
in realtà il motivo è perché siamo
ancora dal 92 in una transizione e
questa realtà un concetto estremamente
fondamentale quando parliamo di di
cambiamenti a livello societario perché
più è grande la scala di cui parliamo è
più questo concetto di transizione
diventa vitale
quindi in realtà questo diciamo
triangolo di per che ci permette di
arrivare al cambiamento diciamo un po
incompleto infatti bisogna tenere in
considerazione questo questo periodo
sarà fondamentale appunto vedremo nel
nel prossimo esempio che appunto
l'industria chimica oggi la nostra vita
fondamentalmente gira intorno a una
miriade di prodotti servizi e se pensate
non so cellulari porta
trasporti le macchine medicine il cibo
l'elettricità al genere personale è
tutto basato su questo ma voglio farvi
una domanda
immaginate un giorno senza industria
chimica chi secondo voi quale di questi
prodotti o quantomeno chi pensa per
esempio che è meno del 50 per cento di
questi prodotti sarebbe non ci sarebbe
senza l'industria chimica spesso mi
dicono tutti anzi spesso mi mi
rispondono sì sicuramente faranno pochi
ma in realtà purtroppo non è così
presente
tutti questi prodotti
mentre tutto quello che che noi
indossiamo di quello che c'è attorno a
noi fondo viene direttamente o
indirettamente dall'industria chimica
perché in realtà dobbiamo cercare di
immaginarci questo questo giorno magari
fantomatico in realtà un giorno senza
industria chimica e un giorno senza
petrolio quindi perché noi siamo una
società basata sul petrolio che il giro
di secoli se non facciamo nulla potrà
fondamentalmente finire vi spiego perché
questa società è fatta diciamo così
questa chimica inizia chimica è
praticamente l'industria chimica è come
un albero semplicemente si può
tutti questi prodotti servizi sono
appunto come le foglie di quest'albero
questi cosiddetti consumer goods questi
qua sono fatti a sua volta da prodotti
intermedi per così dire combinazioni
chimiche per così dire di prodotti
intermedi ancora di più
come il tronco punto di quest'albero è
fatto da i cosiddetti elementi della
chimica di base che appunto si possono
unire per cui se dire come facciamo come
un lego per così dire per fare tutti
questi vari intermedi e fino alle radici
di quest'albero dove si trovano in raw
materials ovvero le risorse naturali e
pensate un po infatti quest'albero circa
il 90 per cento di quest'albero oggi si
stima che è basato appunto sul petrolio
quindi immaginate appunto una società
senza questo non è una società quindi
potremmo veramente non vivere come oggi
ovviamente la soluzione finale per
l'unica vera soluzione sostenibile come
che si pensa oggi è appunto riuscire a
utilizzare comunque l'indire carbonica
co2 prodotta in questi in questi
processi è riuscire a chiudere
fondamentalmente il cerchio per poter
avere appunto una cosiddetta economia
circolare il problema è che oggi queste
tecnologie hanno una maturità
tecnologica così bassa diciamo che si
prevede
che queste tecnologie arriveranno a
livello commerciale nei prossimi 50
addirittura cent'anni ma non possiamo
purtroppo aspettare così tanto quindi
come nell'esempio del delle uova c'è
bisogno di una transizione e quando
appunto dobbiamo vogliamo noi andare dal
petrolio fino alla co2 in mezzo deve
esserci qualcosa qualche altra risorsa
che ci possa garantire di fare questo
passaggio
beh ce ne sono tre fondamentalmente tre
possibile che andremo a visualizzare che
sono la biomassa il carbone e il gas
naturale
ora cercheremo di capire i pro e contro
quale di effettivamente cosa anche la
scienza pensa i quali di queste risorse
naturali sono effettivamente migliori o
potrebbero veramente riuscire in questa
transizione e lo faremo tramite
fondamentalmente tre parametri che ci
diranno appunto quanto la questa risorsa
e abbondante quanto il suo impatto a
livello dell'ambiente e l'impatto a
livello societario anche la prima ea
biomassa che pur essendo appunto si
parla molto green a un grande svantaggio
come vedevano nella nel punto societario
il problema è che per riuscire a fare
per esempio a produrre della biomassa
bisogna fondamentalmente coltivarla
quindi si stima per esempio che per
riuscire a fare bio plastiche per che
riescono per esempio a coprire il volume
di plastiche del solo
del polietilene del polimero prime due
delle maggiori pras classico usate oggi
si dovrebbero usare circa il 7 per cento
della della terra agricola della terra
coltivabile di tutto il pianeta
quindi la domanda sorge quasi spontanea
dobbiamo coltivare classiche o coltivare
cibo per noi quindi non adatto a livello
quantomeno globale secondo è appunto il
carbone che seppur molto abbondante nel
nostro pianeta ha considerato da fonte
fossile più inquinante che c'è ancora
più del petrolio in realtà è l'ultima è
il gas naturale
un appunto che al contrario del carbone
esattamente su pur essendo una fonte
fossile è considerata la più green tra
tra queste e molti stati stanno piano
piano cambiando stanno cercando di
cambiare loro fixed hoc da petrolio e
gas naturale
il problema
uno dei grossi problemi di oggi col gas
naturale in realtà è che neanche il 10
per cento del gas naturale estratto
tutt'oggi è usato per nell'industria
chimica per fare appunto questi prodotti
kimi questi intermedie press i prodotti
alla chimica di base che parlavamo prima
in realtà si stima che una circa il 3.5
per cento che una stima quasi molto
simile a quello che quel poco che viene
usato nell'industria chimica viene
bruciato nel cosiddetto processo di
flaring così come vedete qua perché il
modo più realtà più economico per
disfarsene
e questo processo in realtà brucia si
stima circa 15 miliardi di dollari ogni
anno
e ancora peggio forse è tutta l'anidride
carbonica che rilascia perché cercate di
immaginare 70 milioni
in questo caso range rover i fuoristrada
che viaggiano per 20mila chilometri ogni
anno rilasciando quindi enormi quantità
di co2 questo avere così un feeling di
quello che questo processo per il nostro
pianeta ma
questo processo in flaring
fondamentalmente dove avviene
principalmente dove il gas naturale
viene estratto come vedete quadro
esempio questo video è il motivo
principale è appunto perché è troppo
costoso tramite per esempio gasdotti
trasportare in molti dei casi questo gas
questi impianti di produzione chimica
dove può essere appunto trasformato e
l'albero può essere iniziati non può
essere formato per così dire la mia idea
la mia visione è che invece di portare
il gas all'impianto è esattamente il
contrario portare l'impianto al gas in
cui il cosiddetto plan on wheels che
praticamente come in questo camion che
arriva al alla risorsa dal punto a al
sito di estrazione del gas evita quindi
di dover trasportarlo riesce appunto
invece a trasformarlo in un on site sul
sito e quindi finire il processo di
flare eliminarlo completamente e questo
è possibile tramite tecnologie che
stanno sono in fase di sviluppo oggi una
dei quali una delle quali è quella che
riuso lavorando sviluppato negli ultimi
cinque anni a zurigo in realtà una cosa
importante prima di chiudere è che
questo processo di flaring non è un un
processo che magari viene o un problema
che viene deciso magari da qualche non
so se i con el qualche deserto sperduto
ma in realtà è qualcosa decisa
fondamentalmente da noi o comunque da da
chi ci rappresenta e voglio farvi un
esempio molto molto forte
degli stati uniti che sono anche un
paese produttore di gas naturale nel già
nel durante il governo obama il suo
governo aveva messo fuori una legge che
è appunto stabiliva o quantomeno
regolava questo processo di fleming che
ahimè già nel 2000 viene 17 col governo
trump è stata ovviamente eliminato
questo ha già è già costato nell'ultimo
anno si stima circa un miliardo di
dollari per di perdite del al governo
americano più enormi quantità di co2
ovviamente rilasciate nell'atmosfera
quindi di conseguenza
tornando alla fine alle come
nell'esempio nell'uovo dove nel caso
della svizzera
questo è il popolo sito ha deciso
conscio di fare di adottare un
cambiamento per il bene della società in
quel caso della città svizzera
noi oggi abbiamo il dovere di essere
appunto consci di quello che succede è
quello di quali innovazioni abbiamo noi
bisogno soprattutto per il bene per
riuscire ad avere un cambiamento per il
bene delle generazioni future e
soprattutto per il bene del nostro
pianeta
grazie
[Applauso]